you
how did we begin what attracted me to
the project was that it was very clear
what was happening in the developing
world hundreds of millions of people in
Africa and the developing world were
getting cell phones this was the only
growth area in telephony in 2003 2004
the only segment that was making money
and it was changing the GDP of these
countries because every percent
penetration of cellphones you'd get you
know a certain amount of gdp growth but
there was studies showing that if you
could get data to these people not just
voice but data the impact could be three
four or five times greater for every
percent penetration you could get but
but how do you you know make something
for the developing world and get them to
them no that's when I ran into Nicholas
Negroponte a who said hey you know let's
make a hundred dollar laptop and let's
get the government's to buy the laptops
on mass and give them you know one two
one one laptop per child and I thought
oh my gosh Nicholas figured out the
business model of course we became
nonprofit to do this business but then
it became my job to make the
hundred-dollar laptop cost a hundred
dollars which you know it is a little
bit more expensive we could have hit 150
it's at 188 and there's reasons for that
and I can I can defend them but still
it's the lowest cost laptop ever made
the lowest power laptop ever made and
the greenest laptop ever made and all of
that comes from looking at it from the
screen backwards the screen is what
people see when they see the laptop
there could be little green men inside
of electronics it wouldn't wouldn't make
any impact to somebody looking at the
laptop the screen and the housing or
what we see and so if you can lower the
cost of this screen and the electronics
behind it and lower the power
consumption you can deliver amazing
results
the whole architecture the display most
displays have motherboards so the
question was how do you make a display
that costs less than a hundred dollars
because that's a real barrier to $100
laptop and what what do you do with the
motherboard it was very clear we had to
get rid of the hard disk right and moved
to what we call flash and use a smaller
processor skinny down the operating
system and also massively lower the
power consumption but that really came
from choosing really noticing working
with with with the the chip manufacturer
I asked them a question I asked him
every month for about six months and
they finally answered this question how
much power does it take to just keep the
screen on even if the pixels aren't
changing well the answer was 223 watts
and at that point I had reinvented a
screen that was you know one watt
instead of usual a usual screen this is
like seven watt power consumption and so
so I just thought that was stupid to
sort of keep a cpu on to you know
consume 2 to 3 watts plus the whole
motherboard just to drive a screen with
the same pixels on all the time say
you're reading something and just the
pixels aren't moving around there's no
video on the screen everything's sort of
the same well it turns out that um I
know a lot about display but maybe the
people you know I didn't know this is
going to be so technical I'm just
wondering how to do a technical talk to
non-technical audience
you